ein eigenes fahrrad kann sie sich nicht
leisten und so fährt teilnahm auf einem
der schweren leihfahrräder dies hier in
rio an jeder ecke gibt die stadt ist
stickig der verkehr lebensgefährlich
jeden tag gekämpft die sich hierdurch um
für einen online lieferdienst essen
auszufahren für die menschen die wegen
der katastrophalen corona lage nicht
mehr vor die tür gehen ich habe kleine
kinder vor allem deshalb habe ich angst
mit kuwait anzustecken
aber ich muss arbeiten die größere angst
ist die arbeitslos zu werden
die korona pandemie bietet einfache jobs
wie diesen doch langfristig ist das
keine perspektive
tyler ist 24 und vierfache mutter sie
hat einen schulabschluss doch weil sie
ihre kinder ernähren muss kann sie
wieder studieren noch eine ausbildung
machen ich habe keine ausbildung bei
bewerbungen zeige ich meinen lebenslauf
in dem praktisch nichts drinsteht andere
bewerber sind besser qualifiziert als
ich deshalb habe ich mich dann für diese
arbeit entschieden
kaymer gehört zur gruppe junger leute
die ökonomen als die weder noch
generation residenz bezeichnen weder ein
studium noch ein fester job
sie kommt aus ärmsten verhältnissen und
war gut in der schule
doch jetzt muss sie schnelles geld
verdienen jung intelligent und doch
abgehängt das drama einer ganzen
generation
diese generation von jugendlichen die
weder studieren noch arbeiten die von
gelegenheitsjobs leben wird große
probleme haben in der zukunft auf dem
regulären arbeitsmarkt eine stelle zu
finden
hinzu kommt dass es gerade die ärmeren
sind die in der pandemie ihr leben
riskieren
ein leben mit sicherheitsabstand können
sie sich nicht leisten sie sind das
öffentliche gesundheitssystem angewiesen
und das ist weitgehend zusammengebrochen
die korona zahlen erreichen immer neue
rekorde menschen sterben während sie auf
ein freies intensiv mit warten
gerade unter den jungen leuten steigt
die zahl der opfer rasant an
ein sicheres leben eine gesicherte
zukunft scheint unendlich weit weg
genauso wie das meer hier oben in der
favela salgueiro einem von hunderten
armenviertel der stadt
manche der kinder hier waren noch nie am
meer
auch teile stammt aus einer solchen
favela hier liegen die wurzeln der
großen ungleichheit brasiliens die
kinder der favelas sind die großen
verlierer der gesellschaft armut und
gewalt prägen den alltag wir hier
geboren ist hat kaum eine chance
schulen und kindergärten sind wenn
vorhanden schlecht ausgestattet und seit
einem jahr ohnehin komplett geschlossen
wegen der pandemie
anna will das nicht hinnehmen
sie stammt selbst von hier tagsüber
unterrichtet sie an privatschulen in den
wohlhabenderen vierteln der stadt abends
ehrenamtlich hier in der favela zum
unterricht gibt es immer eine
kleinigkeit zu essen dass anna von ihrem
eigenen geld gekauft hat es gibt kinder
die kommen ohne irgend etwas gegessen zu
haben
es ist sehr schwer wir versuchen ihnen
zumindest eine mahlzeit zu geben keine
richtige mahlzeit aber wenigstens etwas
um den magen zu füllen
heute steht mathe auf dem programm 6 und
1 ist wieviel sehr gut
jetzt mache ich noch mal zwei dazu ich
vermisse die schule sehr und bin traurig
dass wir immer noch keine schule haben
wegen der pandemie wichtiger als der
lernstoff ist das lernen selbst das
versprechen dass bildung ein ausweg sein
kann
wir wollten den kindern helfen indem wir
sie von der straße holen und sie zum
lernen bringen wir glauben dass wir so
ein samenkorn in ihrem kopf einpflanzen
können aus dem die überzeugung wächst
dass aus ihnen gute erwachsene werden
können
dass das leben nicht nur aus dem besteht
was ich hier erleben
das leben ist so viel mehr als dass hier
lernte einst selbst hier und will ein
vorbild für die kinder sein deren eigene
eltern können das oft nicht sagt uns
joyce die ihre tochter marlies soll
abholt wenn es das hier nicht gäbe ich
könnte nicht helfen ich weiß selbst
nicht viel ich hatte keine möglichkeit
in die schule zu gehen
der weg aus der favela ist für viele
unerreichbar
gerade auch weil es an bildungschancen
fehlt und die pandemie macht das alles
noch schlimmer
so ist es auch marco ergangen er hat
eigentlich alles richtig gemacht auch er
stammt aus einer favela
doch er schaffte das schier unmögliche
ein studienabschluss als bauingenieur an
der besten universität von rio
doch dann wurde er trotzdem arbeitslos
die baubranche ist seit langem in der
krise und die pandemie hat der
wirtschaft den rest gegeben
an meiner uni hieß es du wirst einen job
haben eine super karriere machen und
nichts davon ist passiert statt große
häuser zu bauen renoviert er nun
privatwohnungen
wenigstens ist er sein eigener chef mit
dem verlegen von led leisten und
holzpaneelen kämpft er ums
wirtschaftliche überleben
doch meist reichen diese aufträge nicht
und so arbeitet marco zusätzlich als
fahrer für einen online taxidienst jedes
wochenende und wenn sonst zeit
ein extrem stressiger job bis zu 18
stunden ist er unterwegs in den
verstopften straßen von rio damit es
sich lohnt
hinzu kommt die ständige gefahr nicht
nur wegen krone
es ist extrem gefährlich heute erst ist
am frühen morgen ein taxifahrer getötet
worden
er wurde überfallen während er auf einen
fahrgast wartete als er sich wehrte
haben sie ihn einfach erschossen
wer aus armen verhältnissen kommt führt
ein leben im ständigen ausnahmezustand
sagt man man hat zwei möglichkeiten
damit umzugehen
entweder man gibt anderen die schuld und
sitzt selbstmitleidig zu hause oder man
kämpft und das machen 90 prozent der
brasilianer
wer kämpfen doch es ist ein extrem
ungleicher kampf wir treffen noch einmal
teil 60 kilometer ist sie heute gefahren
für knapp 10 euro
ich will das nicht für immer machen
ich möchte einmal mehr geld verdienen
und meinen kindern eine zukunft bieten
ich frage mich schon was ich ihnen
hinterlassen werden
am ende der schicht wartet der strand
für einen kurzen moment kann keiner
vergessen was ihr und millionen anderen
jungen brasilianern sorgen bereitet